Practitioners of alternative medicine have recommended ginkgo biloba...
...as a means of maintaining and even improving memory among older adults.
But until now, strong clinical evidence about its effectiveness has not been forthcoming.
This is the first and so far, the only study...
...that has looked specifically at its ability to prevent decline.
For eight years, researchers at six universities across the US...
...studied more than 3,000 adults, aged 72 to 96...
...with normal mental functioning or with mild cognitive impairment.
Participants received either a 120 milligram dose of ginkgo extract twice a day...
...or a sugar pill.
Researchers found that ginkgo had no specific effect on memory or attention.
What we can say is that we find no evidence...
...that ginkgo, over this long period of time, made a difference...
...in whether someone's slow change in memory function, as a function of normal aging...
...was affected at all by the medication.
Earlier research showed that ginkgo did nothing for people with symptoms of Alzheimer's disease...
...nor did it help reduce other forms of dementia.
Researchers say, this latest study is notable...
...because it was conducted with the largest number of participants,...
...and it rules out the herbal supplement as a useful treatment for memory loss.
We found that there was no effect of the ginkgo biloba...
...on these very slow but clearly detectable changes in thinking function in late life.
But the researchers added one caveat.
While ginkgo biloba is not effective in slowing down the mental changes of aging,...
...they say it is safe and has no side effects.
For Vidushi Sinha, I'm Elizabeth Lee, VOA News.